Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Hard Rock Cafe
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Let's break down "the
burger that started it all,"
the original legendary burger.
This is a steak burger
with applewood bacon,
two slices of Tillamook cheddar cheese,
a crispy onion ring, lettuce, and tomato.
On the menu, they really want you to know
that every burger has
two slices of cheese.
Let's weigh the US burger.
318 grams.
Here's the original
legendary burger in the UK.
Let's weigh it.
Our burger weighed 280 grams.
That's a pretty big difference,
from 280 to 318 grams.
This is a heavy, heavy burger.
And, of course, all their burgers
come with a side of seasoned fries.
We're going to weigh ours to
see how much we're getting.
So, our side of fries came to 178 grams.
They feel so soggy right now in my hands.
So, that is 126 grams of french fries.
Another iconic menu
item is baby back ribs.
We're going to weigh our UK portion
to find out how much we're getting.
Is that too heavy?
Charlie: That's too heavy.
335 plus ...
oh, God.
300.
635 grams.
This is heavy.
This is 802 grams of ribs.
That sounds like too much
ribs for one sit-down dinner.
That's a lot of ribs.
The cowboy rib eye is
supposedly 16 ounces of beef.
Let's see if that's actually true.
This is 12.8 ounces of meat.
Meat does shrink,
so a little wiggle room is to be expected,
but that's
a pretty decent chunk.
Crew: Boo!
We booed.
Everyone's booing.
Everyone's booing me.
So, after being booed by everyone,
I'll be more upset about losing out
on some of this meat.
It just looks like such a big portion
that I'm like, it's fine.
But it is 4 ounces that we're missing
that was advertised. So I understand.
I understand why everyone's upset.
Strangely, the cowboy rib eye
is advertised as being
14 ounces here in the UK.
I'm not sure why we're
getting shortchanged,
but we're going to measure
it to keep them honest.
So, our UK cowboy rib eye
has actually only come to
10 ½ ounces.
I understand that steaks
do lose some of their mass
while cooking, but 3 ½
ounces? That seems like a lot.
Let's get into some apps.
We got the classic nachos, no meat.
This is "Food Wars,"
so you know we gotta weigh these nachos.
602 grams.
Here are the UK nachos.
I'm going to weigh them
with the paper because
our scale has had enough trauma already.
Our UK nachos weighed 510 grams.
I'm interested to see which country
has bigger wing portions,
so let's count them out.
Count them out with me. We have one,
two.
Three,
four.
Harry: 10,
11,
and 12.
Nico: Seven,
eight.
I'm going to let them have this one.
I'm going to let them have this one
because we've literally
been destroying them
in these portion sizes this entire time.
So you know what? You deserve
the extra amount of wings.
Hard Rock Cafe is also known
for its famous onion ring tower.
Now, on the menu, they don't specify
how many onion rings you get in a tower.
However, in a promotional
photo, I counted eight.
So we're going to count ours
out now and see if that's true
or if we get more or less
than we were promised.
I'm going to try my hardest to beat Harry
in the onion-ring-tower-making.
Somehow built this the wrong way round,
so it's getting wider near the top.
Six,
seven.
Oh, God, no!
I'm not doing that again.
Eight,
nine,
10.
Girls in STEM.
So, while my tower design failed horribly,
we did get 11 onion rings
in our onion ring tower as a side.
What about dessert?
Let's compare Hard Rock's apple cobbler
in the US and the UK.
It smells so good.
I'm resisting every urge I have
to bite into it right now.
We've got 432 grams of apple cobbler.
So, the apple cobbler in
the UK came to 376 grams.
Here are all the menu items you'll find
at a Hard Rock in the UK that
you won't find in the US.
Here's all the food that you'll find
at Hard Rock Cafe in the US
that you won't find in the UK.
There are a couple of burgers you'll find
in the US but not in the UK,
the turkey burger and
the Impossible burger.
I think Impossible beef isn't
available in the UK yet.
There's an ingredient in it
called soy leghemoglobin,
which is approved in the
US but not in the UK.
The Impossible burger.
That soy leghemoglobin is
doing what it needs to do.
That's the ingredient
that makes this taste
like actual beef, and it's
working. It's working for me.
I can tell texture-wise,
in the back of my head,
this is not beef,
but it's doing enough
where I don't really care.
It tastes pretty good.
There's also a small difference
in the classic legendary
burger in the two countries.
The UK uses just regular cheddar cheese,
while the US specifically
uses Tillamook cheddar.
Tillamook is a popular
creamery based in Oregon.
I'm not going to bite
into everything here today
because we are going to
give some of this away,
but if there's anything that
catches my eye particularly,
then I'll give it a try.
We actually have quite a
few exclusives in the UK,
so I'll start at this
end and work my way down.
First off, we have cauliflower tacos.
I think they are pretty
much as the name suggests.
It's a taco, which is a,
I think is a flour tortilla
with some pieces of seasoned
cauliflower in there
as well as some slaw, some
sauce, and some jalapeños.
Next up, we've got barbecue chicken.
This one really just does
what it says on the tin.
It's just half of a chicken,
which has been grilled and
covered in barbecue sauce.
It's almost unnerving
how accurately they have
halved this chicken.
It's literally like they've just gone
straight through the middle
of it with, like, a laser beam
and sliced the thing in two.
The next exclusive menu
item is fish and chips.
You get this a lot. You
might have a company
which branding-wise seems
like it's not from the UK,
but when they launch in the UK,
they feel compelled to have
fish and chips on the menu.
I will have to try this one.
I can't let them off the hook
if they've really
butchered fish and chips.
Although I will give them,
again, some credit for the fact
that this has been
sitting around for a while
and therefore has lost all of the crisp
which I think it once had.
It's not too bad.
I do think had we eaten
this hot and fresh,
it would've been a bit crispier.
You can definitely see some
of the flakes of batter
which would've crisped up.
Next up, we have the
Moving Mountains burger.
Now, we don't have the Impossible burger
on the UK menu because as of right now,
Impossible beef still
cannot be sold in the UK.
Moving Mountains is a company
which does very similar things.
It's making plant-based meat alternatives,
including a beef burger, which is approved
for sale in the UK and is on offer here.
I mean, visually, I gotta say
the Moving Mountains burger
does look pretty good.
It's got a nice brown exterior.
They've got the kind of grainy,
like, meat fibers, almost, in the middle,
and it definitely looks a bit pink, even.
I'm quite impressed by that.
That's really not bad.
Obviously it doesn't
have the exact beef taste
that you're used to, but
there's definitely a meatiness to it.
Every Hard Rock Cafe location
also has a local burger
which is inspired by
ingredients found in that area.
So this is the London burger.
On here, you'll find a beef patty
with some layers of roast beef,
a horseradish mayo, rocket,
some tomato, and some lettuce.
Now, the London burger is loosely inspired
by a British Sunday roast,
specifically the roast beef.
I do think I need to taste this
to see if it's giving an
accurate representation
of British cuisine.
They've been fairly generous
with the roast beef slices, I have to say.
Cheers.
You definitely do get
that roast beef flavor
from these pieces of beef.
I think it could maybe have done
with even more horseradish mayo,
because the flavor of
that is really lovely.
It's pretty good.
Whether it's a accurate
representation of London
and London cuisine, I'm
going to go with no.
But is it a tasty burger?
Kind of, yes.
New York City doesn't have
a region-specific burger,
but they do offer a French
dip on garlic bread.
Joe made me aware that the French dip
was not created in New
York, but rather LA.
But I can kind of see
where they were going.
what they were going for
because roast beef sandwiches in general
are popular here. That
includes French dips.
And they might have
chosen the garlic bread
because New York City has so much Italian
and Italian American
culture ingrained in it.
I feel like I'm kind
of reaching right now,
but I'm just trying to
make sense of it all.
This is the garlic bread
that they speak of.
Um, I think we need to have
some words with Hard Rock Cafe.
What is the sauce called?
Bless you.
Got her.
Got both of them.
I'm taking a dip. I'm taking a dip.
You can do it! You can do it!
This is the coldest au jus
and the coldest French dip.
This is just not it.
Go somewhere else. Go somewhere else!
Hard Rock Cafe has also partnered
with the greatest footballer of all time,
Lionel Messi.
Now, I'm not sure if
Messi's diet allows him
to regularly eat at Hard Rock Cafe.
However, he's partnered with
them to release two burgers.
You can find the Messi beef burger
in both the US and the UK,
but in the UK we have an exclusive one,
the Messi chicken burger.
Let's just take a look
and see what we can find.
So, we have what looks to
be maybe a potato roll.
We've got some bacon, some cheese,
a big grilled chicken breast.
There is some sauce on here as well.
Mayonnaise.
As well as tomato and lettuce.
If I take a bite out of this,
do you think I will gain
the footballing ability
of Lionel Messi?
Whether that is a sandwich
fitting for the GOAT,
I'm not sure.
Speaking of Messi,
I think now's a great time to quiz Joe
and see if he can pick him
out in a group of photos.
He is one of the most famous
men in the entire world,
so it shouldn't be hard. Right, Joe?
So, one of these persons is Lionel Messi,
and I don't know which one he is.
Well, this guy's from "Ted Lasso,"
so I'm assuming it's not him,
or someone would've said at some point,
"Can you believe that guy
is also a famous soccer player?"
This looks like a person
who works in a café.
So I'm going to assume that's not him.
Tough times for football
players, apparently.
I mean, this just looks like,
I feel like I've seen this guy somewhere.
I feel like this guy works at Insider.
Who's this?
This can't be him.
This looks like a stock photo.
And then this looks like a guy
from, like, a background
extra in "The Matrix," so.
So I'm going to think that it's this guy.
Oh, it's not?
This guy?
Yuelei: Yeah.
This guy is this super-famous
football soccer player?
So, I think I was right.
This is Shutterstock, though.
Hey, what do you want from me?
None of this means anything to me.
Both countries also have
exclusive cocktails.
If you're in the mood to
spend $20 on a margarita,
I have just the place for you.
When you buy one of the $20 cocktails,
you do get to keep the collectible glass
that it comes in, so that's kind of fun.
Imagine how happy and
fulfilling my life would be
if I just had a Hard Rock
glass in my hand right now.
A legendary burger in the
US contains 1,610 calories.
Now, I don't know if
they mean 1,610 calories
with the fries or without,
so just keep that in mind.
According to the FDA, that is 81%
of my daily recommended caloric intake.
Here in the UK, the
original legendary burger
contains 1,375 calories,
which, according to FDA guidelines,
is around 69% of my daily
recommended allowance.
A lot of food items on the Hard Rock menu
are actually super high in calories,
including the baby back ribs,
which clock in at 2,433 calories.
Here in the UK, the baby back ribs
contain around 1,796 calories,
which makes the US version
around 35% more calorific.
More detailed nutritional
info for Hard Rock Cafe
doesn't seem to be available online,
but I did notice this
little tiny salt symbol
that was next to a whole bunch of dishes.
This indicates that the
sodium content of that item
is higher than the total
daily recommended limit,
which is 2,300 milligrams.
There's something about a fudge brownie
with vanilla ice cream
that feels very American food chain.
In the US, this dessert contains
1,122 cals.
I think it's worth it, though.
This thing looks really good.
In the UK, the fudge
brownie with ice cream
comes to 2,009 calories.
What we have here is the takeaway version,
which I personally do not think
contains 2,000 calories.
I think what they're referring to
is the in-restaurant version,
which is an enormous
chocolate fudge sundae
with loads of ice cream, sauces, and more.
In front of me now, I have a
starter of 12 chicken wings
with Buffalo sauce; I have the main,
which is the legendary burger and fries;
and I have dessert, which
is an apple cobbler.
Now, I would say this is
a fairly standard dinner.
I think it would be on the heavier side
for a dinner, but if I was hungry,
I could definitely polish off
all three courses, no problem.
However, if I ate all of this,
I would be consuming 4,819 calories.
I think those daily-caloric-intake values
might be outdated and vary
depending on the person.
I'm not a nutritionist.
I'm just a girl.
In the US, an order of Buffalo
wings, a legendary burger,
and a hot fudge brownie
would cost around $52.97.
Why in God's green earth
is this burger $20?
It looks good. Just not $20 good.
Hard Rock Cafe is a theme restaurant,
and I feel like with a theme restaurant
also comes pretty high prices.
I think that's because they're
kind of tourist-trap-y.
They think people are willing to pay more
because it's an experience
and not just the food.
In the UK, the same meal
would cost you £43.85,
which is $56.56.
All of this food for £43
is kind of a lot of food,
and, as we've discussed,
a lot of calories,
but also, I don't think I'm getting
that much value for my money.
I feel like even in London,
I can find better value elsewhere,
and I do think it's kind of being marketed
as kind of a tourist trap
or maybe kind of a
special-occasion treat meal.
Did you know that the first Hard Rock Cafe
was actually opened in London?
It was the Hyde Park branch,
and it opened in 1971.
It's pretty rare to come
across a Hard Rock Cafe
if you don't live in a major city
or tourist destination.
I think because of that reason,
they're not super popular here,
even though they are popular
in the sense that we know what it is.
There are only 34
locations in the entire US,
and six of those are in Florida.
18% of the Hard Rock Cafes
in America are in Florida.
But this is an international chain,
so you can find Hard Rock Cafes
in over 50 countries, including Armenia,
Nepal, Nigeria, and Poland.
Hard Rock Cafe does have
a very dedicated fan base.
There's a community of collectors
who will buy and swap commemorative merch
from the different locations,
including things like
the pins and, of course,
the iconic T-shirts and jumpers.
Some superfans even celebrate
Hard Rock milestones
like visiting your 25th location.
I think I've got maybe 24 to go.
Same. All we have to do is go to Florida,
and we can cross six more off our list.
They sell normal American fare,
which I can find anywhere,
like at a Chili's or an Applebee's,
chains that are much more available.
The thing that makes Hard
Rock Cafe special, though,
isn't the food, it's the memorabilia.
The first piece of memorabilia
donated to Hard Rock Cafe
was Eric Clapton's Lead II Fender in 1979.
Since then, they have
amassed quite the collection,
with 86,000 pieces worldwide.
Supposedly, it is the
largest private collection
of music memorabilia in the entire world.
These days, the memorabilia is
still either donated to them
or sometimes purchased through auctions.
There are some pretty
cool pieces out there,
including Elvis Presley's
24-karat gold leaf piano,
handwritten lyrics for
John Lennon's "Imagine,"
and, of course, One
Direction's iconic phone box,
which they used in
their album cover shoot.
I am so jealous that Harry
got to take a picture
with the One Direction phone booth.
I don't care if something
good happened to you.
It should have happened to me instead.
I did manage to get a picture
with one of Beyoncé's outfits
from her "Green Light" music video.
It's not as iconic as the
"One Direction" phone booth,
but it's something.
We have a quote here from one of the
Hard Rock Cafe founders which
we think is quite interesting.
It says, "The Hard Rock
Cafe Mayfair's grace
was becoming London's
first classless restaurant
at a time when a baker and a banker
could not commune, live,
shop, or dine together."
I think they might be
reaching a little bit here.
I do think that London in the '70s
was kind of in its punk era.
I think social barriers were
already being torn down.
We'd already had the kind of
hippie movement in the '60s.
I don't think Hard Rock
Cafe can really claim
that they were the only ones
to break down social barriers.
And there is nothing more
punk than the Hard Rock Cafe.